hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that they just finished in
the ftx road to miami preliminaries it
is levon arenan versus sergey arjun and
it's quite a quite a brilliant game you
guys started requesting it as soon as it
ended and as always for for very good
reasons uh it really
shows you the power of the bishop pair
and how you can never take the bishop
pair for granted uh especially when uh
you know uh wielded with such deadly
purpose as you will witness here so
let's check it out lavon has the white
piece and he opens with e4 now it's a
pretty standard uh opening nothing uh
you know spectacular c5 um yeah it goes
for the sicilian defense knight f3 d6
and now bishop to c4
we have knight to f6 and the d3 so uh
just nicely developing e6 we have
castles bishop to a7 uh we have a4
and when i said that nothing interesting
is happening i lied because it is
already now as of move six that we have
a completely new game now before this a4
move the position is a known one and
it's been played by many top players uh
uh ronyan included uh and probably eric
started his games and as he knew who
would be playing in this tournament for
example uh there is a game where c3 was
played by lavon himself
he played it in 2020 in the skilling
preliminaries against tanish geary and
he was able to win the game but here he
prepared a4 and uh oh now it's very very
interesting as it's only move six so
let's see how the game continues we have
castles uh knight b to d2 and the knight
to c6 so both players just nicely
developing their pieces rook to e1 with
a6 and c3 so very standard moves uh at
some point white is hoping to push b4 uh
d4 of course is coming and you want to
maybe play knight to f1 maybe knight to
e3 knight to g3 all depending on what
black plays so bishop to d7 nicely
continuing development bishop to b3 and
b5 now uh now uh the the a file will
open up we have knights to f1 and queen
to c7 developing the queen connecting
rooks knights to g3 and now rook f the
c8 we have bishop to f4 now preventing
black from moving that uh d6 pawn and
the queen to b7 uh we have a capture sun
b5a captures and a nice trade of rooks
and the a file rook captures queen
captures and now pawn to d4 so
everything pretty standard uh pretty
much everyone would play this c captures
on d4 we have c captures and now knight
to b4 and here you can see that um arjun
is really putting pressure on white's
position the e4 pawn being pressured
currently is defended so it's nothing uh
spectacular the the knight and rook are
nicely controlling the c file that c2
square the d3 score also covered by the
knight but the bishop on b3 doing a fine
job so nothing to worry about uh so uh
levon starts uh an attack on the king
side with his signature h4 move we have
h6 uh pawn to h5 uh continuing to push
on the king side and bishop to f8 we
have queen to d2 now putting pressure on
this uh h6 pawn so you can see how
bishop f8
does make sense because if this bush
wasn't here there is no doubt level and
would just go for bishop captures on h6
with the queen and two knights here it
would be very difficult to defend this
you can imagine this rook being lifted
uh very very scary stuff so night back
to c6
bishop to c2 the bishop pair now nicely
targeted at black's king side and queen
to a5 here now arjuna offers a queen
trade and levon politely declines he
plays queen to d1 with e5 now
challenging the bishop and the bishop
back to d2 attacking the queen here so
queen to a2 and now just point the d5
attacking the knight we have knights to
d4 and levon traits knight captures e
captures and now that he messed up
arjun's uh uh pawn structure a little
bit he goes for a queen trade and plays
a queen to b1
uh offering that queen trade uh and uh
you might think that okay probably a
queen trade will not occur we're gonna
see queen day six or queen day seven but
uh arjun trades queens have queen
captures the bishop captures and now
bishop to g4 going after that h5 pawn
and this is where things start to go
very wrong for arjun uh as well this is
uh this is definitely a poison pawn as
you'll see pawn to f3 levon even forces
him to capture it bishop captures an h5
and now knight to f5 going after that d4
pawn and you can see how this bishop
doesn't have all that much to do here
now we have knight to d7 re-maneuvering
the knight over to e5 and now rook to c1
uh levon wants to get rid of the the
rooks because this rook is very nicely
controlling the c file whereas lavon's
rook on e1 isn't really doing all that
much so rook to a8 arjun declines this
and now knight captures and d4 going
after the b5 pawn we have knights to e5
uh and here we have bishop to f4 now
instead of this bishop to f4 move by
lavon as his position is much better
here bishop to c3 here is stronger just
uh lining up the bishops towards the the
black king and now you don't really the
the the pawn will fall so you you're
going to win this pawn and you're going
to have a beautiful pass beep on and of
course if black tries to defend it nice
the c6 is just very very strong you're
now attacking the knight here twice if
you ever trade here then white gets a
pass pawn on on c6 so yeah white will uh
win this very easily uh but okay uh
bishop to f4 was played and this kind of
gives
arjun a chance to fight back with f6 now
uh adding more defense to the knight
here knight captures on b5 and rook to
b8 so okay levon did win the pawn he
does have the pass beep on and he's
ready to start pushing that pawn uh and
here uh it's not easy to find um
an active uh plan for for the one but
something like knight to d4 does go a
long way however he decides for knight
captures on e5 and now uh arjun
basically equalizes the position d
captures an e5 here and now bishop the
back bishop to d3 uh defending that uh
knight here rook to b1 is coming and
then we're gonna start pushing the b
pawn so bishop to e8 attacking the
knight and now knight to c7 with bishop
to d7 and now knight to e6 we have
bishop to d6 uh and now finally rook to
b1 uh
uh getting ready to start pushing that
uh past pawn
and you can see that lavon is up upon
but he's up against a bishop pair so
let's see how this plays out we have
king to f7 bishop to c for now we have
g6 and now pawn to b3 so the structure
is now very well defended and there's no
good way for
arjun to try and take advantage of
anything here we have rook to a8 now he
would very much enjoy playing rook to a2
but levon just uh continues pushing g4
we have rook to a2 allowing uh arjun
this bit of activity here and rook to c1
we have king to e7 and now rook to c3 uh
defending the the third rank as he
doesn't really have all that much to
worry about the bishop's pair is scary
uh if uh
set free however here the bishop player
isn't really doing all that much you if
you know the the these two diagonals
were open for the bishops then you would
have something to worry about especially
with the rook you know on the second
rank and free to go to the first rank
whenever whenever uh possible so bishop
to b4 now attacking the rook and rook
back to c1 we have h5 arjun creates a
pass pawn so that that definitely goes
in his favor captures captures and king
to h1 now lemon says all right i don't
really have an active plant here i don't
know how to try and push my past beep on
uh and uh arjun starts pushing his pass
pawn pawn to h4 we've rooked to g1 going
after rook to g7 and just king to d6 and
here levon goes for rook to g7 also an
interesting idea is rook to g6
you go after the pawn directly and if
king is seven now you kick away the king
and after king d6 rook f7 and then you
win the pawn so that's one way to do it
but levon plays rook to g7 right away
and now we have bishop to e1 and now you
can already see that the bishop spare
might become uh scary if the knight
moves then the bishop has access to h3
this bishop can come to g3 it will be
defended their rook to h2 becomes
possible so you know it's uh it's still
better for lavon but it's not definitely
not pleasant we have knights to d8 uh
and now comes bishop to c8 so not even
allowing any uh tricky rook captures and
these seven ideas in the future the
bishop will be much safer here and also
just guarding that b7 square uh and here
we have knight the f7 with check uh here
is a great opportunity for lavon to
start pushing that b pawn and again uh
you really have to check this at any
point in the game you have to check if
pushing that b pawn at least is
something good i'm not saying it leads
to something good in absolutely every
position but as you've seen on this
channel it does in most of them because
okay you're attacking the rook you
started pushing the past pawn and you
have to play rook day one here but it's
not unimaginable that something like
rook to c2 happens and now okay what do
you do with the bishop let's say you go
bishop to a6 you want to trade uh or you
even sacrifice this bishop bishop
captures an a6 and now rook to a7 you go
after the bishop and let's say the
bishop moves or something and then
knight to f7 checkmate so yeah it's in
the position and this of course is made
possible by this pawn being on b4
preventing the king from escaping to c5
you can see that everything is nicely
defended here so you know you you always
have to check whether b4 does something
so okay knight to f7 check first by
levon king to c5 and now knight captures
an e5 now sort of sacrificing um a
knight but not really because rook the
c7 check will win back the piece so
arjun doesn't even capture the knight he
activates the king even further king to
d4 knight to c6 check king to e3 and now
pawn to d6 levon starts pushing his pass
pawn now d7 is coming and it seems like
arjun is completely busted and both of
them are extremely low on time you can
see that even something that peter lecko
mentioned here uh in the quote above the
board one of the most spectacular
sequences of moves with a few seconds on
the clock that i've ever seen and you
will soon understand why
here bishop to h3 was played
which makes sense you want to take away
as many squares from the black king as
possible if the bishop here would cover
this square you will put this bishop
here to control this square and then
rook to a1
might result in checkmate at some point
or many many other tactics are possible
but here bishop to h3 was played which
seems like a similar idea but you have
you have to start with bishop to g3 but
okay not a lot of time on the clock but
now levon has a chance to
fight back with bishop to f1 he can
sacrifice the bishop in order to free up
the d7 square so he can start pushing
this pawn otherwise black can just give
up the bishop for this pawn so bishop
captures on f1
uh irrigation accepts this and now ponte
d7 preparing the queen the pawn but now
bishop to e2 levon brings a queen into
the game and now bishop captures an f3
with check and what do you do here you
can move the king or you can block with
the rook if you move the king and not
really all that great bishop to f2
checking h2 and now you just get
checkmated bishop g3 with check uh and
uh well that's pretty much it it's a
double check so you can't give up the
rook for the bishop you have to move the
king and now rook a1 check and we get
the position that we've discussed all of
these squares are now taken you have to
block with the queen and then you get
checkmated so instead after bishop
captures an f3 check rook to g2 live on
blocks and now of course uh what
can arjun do next he goes for rook
captures on g2 much better than bishop
captures now you are threatening all
sorts of nasty discoveries and if you
give black one move that's just it so
you have to be extremely precise uh how
you check the black king and levon is
not very precise in this position he
plays queen to d for check and it looks
like such a such an appealing move uh
because who wouldn't but at the way to
go with queen to b6 point being that
after the king starts running away
doesn't really matter where you're gonna
play queen back to d8 and now if you go
here uh we just repeat and if you go
down the board let's say king to c1 we
can play queen captures on f6 and now
you are attacking the bishop so no nasty
discoveries are really possible if you
play something like rook to g3 to guard
the bishop we just move king to h2 and
the game continues there is no immediate
checkmate uh and uh well the the the
white queen is ready to continue
harassing the black king but this is all
very easy in analysis after the actual
game when you're playing a rapid game a
few seconds on the clock of course it's
not easy to spot such a thing levon
played queen to d4 and it does seem like
a much more natural move uh but now the
problem is king to e2 queen to c4 with
check king to f2 and now queen to c5
would check but after king to f1 it was
in this position on move 60 that levon
aryan resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here i would
even ask you to pause the video here to
figure out why but of course you guys
know why uh it's actually mate in one or
mating two if white doesn't deliver a
checkbook let's say white delivers a
check queen to c4 with check you
actually deliver checkmate with black by
stopping white's check so
rook blocks check and delivers checkmate
from the bishop so that's what would
actually happen sullivan did not want to
allow this on the board after king to f1
he resigned the game and a spectacular
victory for arjun eric
with the black pieces against uh a
master of tactics uh lebron
and it just shows you how how strong it
is um
even when you're down a pawn it doesn't
really matter if you have the bishop
pair you can always fight it's merely a
matter of freeing those bishops but uh
you know at any point do check if for
example instead of a knight to f7 check
if a move like pawn to b4 is possible
it's a free move it comes with tempo and
you know okay rook to a1 is still good
for black but white will always be a
little bit better but we've seen how you
can completely blender the game if you
play something like rook to c2 so just
saying you know if there's a possibility
to push the b pawn do check what happens
if if you push it uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it and thank
you very much for suggesting it as soon
as it finished even though i was uh
following the uh the the coverage live
so i did see it as soon as it happened
but uh i'm always uh very grateful when
you guys suggest such wonderful games uh
i would like to thank matteo georgia
alice cluster harbor uh coleman dean
valeris and stephen abrams for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event uh until it finishes uh
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day